well nevada beginning to see the fallout
in terms of cobid numbers
rising which could be the result of
nevadans maybe not following exact
restrictions over
thanksgiving weekend that's according to
the state's covid 19 response director
the i-team's vanessa murphy joins us now
live from her home with a bit more
vanessa
yeah brian the numbers just keep going
up this is a surge right now and do you
remember
throughout the pandemic especially
earlier on we kept hearing about
flattening
the curve and how important that was
that is just
not happening in southern nevada right
now caleb cage the state's kovid 19
response director says
we may just be starting to see the
results from thanksgiving weekend
meaning
from people traveling and socializing
the numbers are concerning and
cage points to one in particular the
reproduction rate of the virus which has
remained at
1.07 or 1.08
for more than a month to get the virus
under control he says
it needs to be less than one
as it means that for every if every
person infected they are now infecting
one or less people right now the
for every person infected there are an
additional 1.07
persons infected
doses of the kovic 19 vaccine could
arrive in nevada
as early as next week the plan is to
vaccinate
health care workers inside hospitals and
people who live
and work inside nursing homes first as
the state will receive
limited doses week by week now
governor steve siselek's three-week
pause
ends tuesday he was trying to avoid
another shutdown we rely so heavily
on tourism here in nevada but the
numbers
keep going up reporting live vanessa
murphy 8 news now